here we are in problem number eight
problem number eight the total daily
profit p in dollars from producing and
selling X units of a certain product is
given by the function P of X so the
profit as a function of X is equal to 17
x minus 10x plus B where B is a constant
if 300 units were produced and sold
yesterday for profit of nineteen hundred
dollars what is the value of B so we
know that P of 300 300 units the profit
when you did 300 units is nineteen
hundred dollars alright and we want to
figure out be so what is P of 300 so
let's put 300 in here we know it also
equals 1,900 but let's put it here so
it's 17 x 300 minus 10 x 300 + b i just
put 300 in 4x that we're trying to find
the profit for 300 and we know already
that that equals 1,900 that equals 1,900
so what's 17 times 317 times 3 is 51 51
let's add those two zeros minus and
what's 10 x 300 that's 3,000 3,000 plus
B is equal to 1900 and then we get 50
100 minus three thousand minus B is
equal to 1,900 what's 5100 320 100 minus
B is equal to 1,900 minus B is equal to
subtract 2,100 from both sides is equal
to minus 200 b is equal to 200 and that
is choice e next problem
problem number nine I will switch colors
the number that results when integer is
multiplied by itself cannot end in which
of the following digits interesting well
what's the number when it's multiplied
by itself that's like squaring a number
so let's let's kind of study what all
the perfect squares look like so when I
square one I get one when i square to i
get for when i square three i get nine
square for i get 16 5 is 25 6 is 36 7 is
49 8 is 64 so let's look at the numbers
that it can be we can go 9 is 81 looks
like it can be a 1a for a nine I could
keep going 1 for 9 a-6 a 5 and actually
if we went to you know eight and 64 so
it's a 49 is now we're going to do that
and then 10 is a zero right it can also
end in a zero the choice is a well a
short number can and one we need to
figure that out choice B sure a number
contended for choice C sure and I'm
again in five that's 25 as an example
choice D a number can add in six choice
e well none of the numbers we looked at
and in an eight and it seems like
there's a bit of a pattern here that it
tends to be just a set of the subset of
these numbers and also we know that the
other choices choices a through D we can
figure out perfect squares that end in
those in those numbers so we know that
the answer is e next problem problem
number 10 a bag contains only red
marbles blue marbles and yellow marbles
the probability of randomly selecting a
red marble from this bag is one-fourth
red so i guess a probability of red is
equal to one-fourth the probability of
em selecting blue marble is one-sixth
probability of a blue marble is equal to
one-sixth which of the following could
be the total number of marbles in the
bag fascinating so what we need to do is
we need to essentially figure out the
ratio of red to blue
two yellow marbles so first of all
what's the probability of getting a
yellow marble so the probability of
getting a yellow marble is going to be 1
minus DS right so probability of yellow
is going to be 1 minus 1 sixth minus
one-fourth let's see we could put all of
that over 12 plus 12 minus 2 6-3 for its
right minus 3 12's that's one-fourth and
then so that equals was 12 minus 2 10
that equals 7 12 so the probability I
get a yellow marble is 712 right so that
means for every 7 mar of fur so let's
write it all as a denominator of 12 that
makes it actually a lot easier 16 is the
same thing as 2 12 and 14 so the same
thing as 3 12 and they all add up to 12
12 so for every 3 mar red marbles
there's two blue marbles and there's
seven yellow marble is the ratio so red
to blue to yellow yellow is equal to 3
22 27 and with and we know we can only
get this type of a ratio when there's a
total of twelve marbles right there has
to be at least 12 marbles or any
multiple of 12 marbles right if there's
exactly one Blue Marble uh if there's
exactly two blue marbles and there'll be
three red and and seven yellow and
there's has to be at least 22 of the
blue marble so any multiple of 12
marbles will work for this type of ratio
so if we look at the choices if we look
at the choices which of the following
could be the total number of marbles in
the bag so out of all those choices
which of them are multiple of 12 well
choice a is in 10 is into multiple
choice C isn't 18 20 30 well 12 shizit
multiple 12 so choice B is our answer
and we just figured it out if there were
three red to blue and 77 yellow then we
get the correct
abilities the key is just to try to
figure out what the probability of
getting a yellow is and then realizing
the ratios between the two next problem
problem 11 when the sum of a list of
prices is divided by the average of the
prices the result is K what does k
represent so if i take the sum divided
by the average so let me let me let's
say I'm taking the sum of let's say
three numbers so let's say n1 plus n2
plus n3 I could do it n times but just
for simplicity just to kind of and I'm
dividing that by the average I'm
dividing it by the average well what's
the average n1 plus n2 plus n3 divided
by three right and if you divide by a
fraction that's the same thing as
multiplying by the reciprocal so it's n1
plus n2 plus n3 times three over n1 plus
n2 plus n3 so this cancels out and all
we're left with is three which is the
number of numbers we had right and you
could have done this you know with 16 or
20 or whatever I mean you could have
said n1 plus n2 + data data n you know
where I have let's say you know n sub
let's say I have em digits and then
divide that by n1 plus n2 plus bum buh
buh buh n over m n over n and sub M
digits and say well I'm dividing by M
this would have also simple simplified
to M digits that I've when you do what
they said at them in the problem the
result is just the number of prices that
you are summing so that is choice D the
number of prices and it works out
because this sum and this sum will
cancel out next problem let me see fast
if I can fit this one in so I have a
drawing it looks like this
triangle triangle triangle triangle then
dotted lines dotted lines dotted lines
dotted lines it says if the area of the
square and the figure above is 81 and so
they're just saying this is a square if
the area is 81 that we know that this
site is 9 and design is nine right this
is nine times nine and the perimeter of
each of the four triangles is 30 so the
perimeter of each of the four triangles
is 30 so the perimeter is 30 of each of
those what is the perimeter of the
figure outlined by the solid line well
think about it the perimeter of the
solid line that would be this that's
that that's what we want to figure out
well wouldn't that just be the perimeter
of the four triangles and then we want
to subtract out this side this side this
side and this side right the perimeter
of the red part is the perimeter of each
of the triangles added up all four of
them minus the perimeter of the square
inside so the perimeter of the four
triangles is 30 times 4 minus the
perimeter of this which is minus 27
nopes minus 36 so it's 120 minus 36 and
that is I'm a bunch of